well good afternoon and welcome I
married Jane Oh dean of the school of
international public affairs and its
really my great pleasure to welcome you
to today's program which is the Gabriel
silver memorial lecture the Gabriel
silver memorial lecture was established
at ciba and at Columbia in 1949 in
support of public lectures at Columbia
University on subjects of world peace
and international relations this is our
most important annual lecture and past
silver lectures have included some truly
remarkable individuals including dwight
d eisenhower when he was president of
Columbia University Rajiv Gandhi Pascal
Lamy Shirin Ebadi Nobel laureate Larry
Summers and and others and so we really
are proudly carrying forward this
tradition of eminence over lectures by
welcoming Associate Justice Stephen
Breyer to Columbia University thank you
so much for joining us we're really
honored to have this chance to discuss
with Justice Breyer his magnificent new
book the court and the world which is
really an important look at a
challenging and crucial set of questions
how the court in so many areas of law
has come to consider and interact with
the laws of the rest of the world and
it's an incredible privilege for me to
participate in this conversation with
Columbia University President Lee
Bollinger under his leadership columbia
university is taking substantial and
many serious steps to engage what
globalization means for a great research
university he's established a committee
on global thought created our global
centers around the world created other
fora to stimulate deep thinking about
what a truly global university means
intellectually and with respect to
students and faculty I think he's
stimulating in 10
considerations of how the university can
more deeply engage global challenges in
those areas where we are uniquely able
to contribute and of course he's a
wonderful champion of sepa and our
mission but of course president
Bollinger is also one of America's
leading constitutional and First
Amendment scholars of former law school
dean and a leading advocate for
affirmative action diversity and
accessibility in higher education I
think just this week Harvard Law Review
Law Review forum published a commentary
by president Bollinger in advance of a
new ruling in an upcoming case but today
we have an extraordinary opportunity to
hear from justice breyer ladies and
gentlemen please join me in welcoming
University President Lee Bollinger
Justice Breyer were thrilled to have you
with this this afternoon and I'm glad to
have this wonderful audience the subject
here is the world in the court
globalization of legal systems and to my
from my point of view this is extremely
important it is really going to be the
future of the lives of those students
who are here today Justice Breyer has
taken positions on this that I think are
incredibly creative in very very greatly
needed from the standpoint of free
speech Free Press some years ago it had
began to occur to me that as there were
more and more global issues and there
was a global communications technology
the internet that made global
communications possible really
instantaneously for the first time in
human history there was now a need to
think about free speech Free Press on
some kind of global scale and would
there be international norms that we
could evolve over over time and how
should we interpret the First Amendment
the Constitution like this well Justice
Breyer this is this is his subject and
so really very fortunate to have him
here today I think all of us really look
at Justice Breyer as a model justice in
so many ways principled pragmatic these
are words that are used often with an
elegant rider a very very deep thinker
and so with all those things please join
me in welcoming Justice Breyer
thank you
so let's start with sort of if you could
describe Justice Breyer what what is
happening in the world today that looks
like it's making a fundamental change
that is the basis for thinking about the
court and the world in new and different
ways so let's just go first to what is
it that occurred to you to write about
the world that caused you to write this
book well I'm thinking about that I'd
like to thank you for inviting people I
love you in preparation about three or
four weeks ago I went to see Hamilton
have you seen it's very very good yeah I
ask you Hamilton did go to Columbia you
know but there was no law school at that
time think of what he could have done
for this country if there had only been
a law school that's not true so it's
really nice for me to be here you're
interested I thought hoping you know the
normal thing with a book you write a
book he's a friend would have been doing
I've been writing a book oh I read your
book oh you're the one right it's an
accident that's normal but they think
the fact is why did I write this book
and because I wanted to put down on
paper some of the things I've seen in 20
years go back 20 years there were cases
involving internet yet to know something
about what goes on beyond our own chores
laws of other countries or international
law a few another a lot it's going like
that fifteen percent twenty percent
that's a lot so all I'm doing is I'm
giving you a report from the front I
mean on what I you hear these same words
and he started out you see very
carefully the president began to edge
towards a question but she knew I
couldn't answer what is globalization
what is interdependence what do all
these words mean well I saw happened to
answered them and I haven't tried to I
said what we're in the position if
you've read it's a good book I'm not
not i'm not even talking about my book
for a change i mean i'm talking about a
very great novel the Charterhouse in
parma and in the Charterhouse of palm of
the hero five breeze del Dongo is it
waterloo and he's sitting there and the
guns bullets are flying the horses are
running around Napoleon's going back and
forth on this white horse and smoked
everything and del Dongo thanks to
himself you know he says something
really important is going on here I wish
I knew what it was now that's what I
feel when I hear the words
interdependence and globalization and
the kind of question you were asking
right so I thought I might shed some
light on that by giving a certain kind
of lands with which I'm familiar to look
at that question I mean what do I know
for 20 years I know the court and so I
want to say how has the court change in
this respect what do I see on our docket
let me tell you a few of the problems
classified and sort of thought about so
you have categories of what we are
seeing and that might give those who are
interested in that area an opportunity
to draw their own conclusion but give
them a few on what's really a bigger
picture because i thought this bigger
picture has nothing to do with the
philosophy of judges it has to do with
nature changes in the nature of the
world now we can go into some of those
if you'd like you could speak to some of
the examples and what it means to look
to foreign law I mean what are the
consequences of that there are those who
are deeply worried if we refer to
foreign law if you put weight on foreign
law could you speak to some of those
those issues yeah well I'll give you two
or three examples I'll give you the most
dramatic and probably a very important
one will have no idea what the answer is
but all you have to do in your con law
class is to look ask your professor this
is
glad I never taught it you say say what
does the what does the Supreme Court
what's it said about executive power
particularly the power of the President
to act during a national security
emergency what did the founders think of
that I thought because with justice
Jackson said they said he said when you
look into the actual cases you will
discover it's sort of like Joseph trying
to interpret the dreams of Pharaoh you
cannot figure out what they're saying
that you're not alone you miss the good
why because for many many years in many
situations not entirely but most the
supreme court and other courts in the
world followed the advice of Cicero
Cicero 2,000 years ago said my Latin
teacher told me doesn't the 10th grade
and I thought I got a great translation
for it I used to translate it i said but
when the cannons roar the laws fall
silent job but somebody told me at one
time I used it he said the Romans didn't
have cannons so I said well all right
you've got the idea you've got the idea
in wartime the court say nothing go back
to the Civil War Lincoln put tens of
thousands of people in jail Seward
secretary of state called in the British
ambassador he said you see that bail on
my desk i push this once and I can have
anyone I want New York thrown into
prison over here anyone I want in
Indiana tell me does the Queen have such
power so now the court did get into it
but not until the war was over and go
read something about Woodrow Wilson and
World War one and what happened to free
speech then and go back and read
everyone knows this case just about in
world war 2i
word in San Francisco I remember driving
with my mother to tanforan racetrack
which was just south we go down a little
road she said that's tanforan racetrack
that's where they held the Japanese on
their way to camps in the east 70,000
american citizens of Japanese origin
taken against their will and putting
camps in January of 41 februari March
April do it general the sixth in the
sixth the Military District in the
presidio he said well we have 785
instances of signaling to Japanese
submarines offshore and there are six or
seven instances of sabotage Herbert who
j edgar Hoover head of the FBI said
you're wrong there isn't any sabotage we
can deal with it Earl Warren said no put
them in camps Warren said it was the
worst thing you ever did but they did
put them in camps 1944 Fred Korematsu
says I'm going to sue this is ridiculous
I'm an American I haven't done anything
wrong his parents were against it said
don't rock the boat he said I'm rocking
it and he got Ernie bezeq the head of
the ACLU in San Francisco was it used to
play poker with my father's and and the
ACLU by the way wouldn't support him in
the lower courts they did eventually you
see there's a war going on and Korematsu
thought he couldn't lose the case gets
up there by 1944 there's no risk from
the Japanese invasion at that point and
he's sure he can't lose but he lost six
to three and at that moment to lawyers
in the Justice Department and
they had gotten very suspicious of the
Army's rationale and they went to the
FCC and said what about those 728 III
instances of signaling two weeks later
they're back the FCC with a study like
because there wasn't one they were all
but projects you didn't know how to work
the equipment said you did a great job
learning all that so quickly says MSR
burling I don't know which in the FCC
man says no no no we didn't do this now
we did it at the time and we showed it
the general wit he knew it so they write
a footnote because the lawyers the
lawyers of say we're not signing the
brief they write a footnote the person
wrote that footnote who's the nice most
famous law professor just about in it in
this Herbert J Wesley yep Herbert J
Wexler r-okla footnote fabulous footnote
it says we disown the Army completely
and nobody can understand what he said
you have to read it 19 times before you
know so I thought well the court never
read the footnote but I read the
transcript and charley horse key well
known in New Deal days representing the
japanese-american defense league says to
the court read the footnote and read it
to you understand it and you will see
there's no justification for this how in
heaven's name did they lose after all
Murphy wrote a dissent we explained this
perfectly well in the Senate I called
murphy's law clerk Pressman who roamed
the supreme court practice he's now 95
or 98 years old or something and I said
what happened did the Justice Department
sneak in and tell you all that nobody
said this is I don't remember
that's it here we are but but I did
learn this from somebody who's read the
notes that black the people in the
majority black Douglas frankfurter the
liberals in Brown versus for black
walked into that room and he said
somebody has to run this war Roosevelt
or us and we can't so it's roseville
that was the art 70,000 american so by
the time we get to the steel seizure
case Jackson Truman seizes the steel
mills to get steel to the Americans
fighting in Korea and the court says no
you've gone too far the court was saying
Roosevelt you've gone too far it's much
easier to say Roosevelt you're going too
far when Roosevelt is dead and it's
Truman because proven is a lot less
popular so that's what they say now we
come to Guantanamo four cases each one
of those four is one by the detainee
strike down a law which says the
detainees cannot get into court you see
that violates the habeas corpus
provision but the key words it's a long
wind up for a very short pitch what I'm
doing but the key words in that are the
Constitution does not write a blank
check to the president not even in
wartime sandro connor writes those words
i agreed with them and now as soon as
you hear those words as good law
students i'm sure or professors and what
in associates the first thing that
occurs you is fine the Constitution does
not write a blank check fine what kind
of check does it right and we're
criticized a lot for that opinion on the
one hand people say what are you
interfering with the president you think
you know anything about security or
terrorism or any of these other bad
things that could happen to us to which
I can you want to go back to Korematsu
is that what you want you want a
constitution that allows that to happen
well okay then on the other side why
weren't you more specific why didn't you
say something about here
say I see you want me to be truthful
because I don't know what is that that's
what because there is really a problem
and so now that's the whole windup and
the pitch is now what do we do and why
do I ask you that because you're the
ones who got to figure it out you say I
can say a few things that are almost the
level of being trite but I can say there
are ways of finding out the lawyer has
helped the lawyers say when there's an
infringement of civil liberty even doing
during wartime why why do you really
need it mystical questions will arise
there the government will have an answer
is the answer heard in camera or is it
hurt in open court is it hurt with the
other lawyer present or is it ex parte I
mean there are a lot of questions in
here and the lawyers can say why not why
not do it this less restrictive way ok
ok fine which less restrictive what how
are you going to find out and I can say
things such as well I at least what we
can do is find out more than we know
about security problems and look and see
what other countries do maybe we'll
learn something we're not the only ones
in the world that are facing these kinds
of threats nor are we the only ones who
have traditions of civil liberties and
democracy let's see what they do let's
work on it together but working out
those kinds of things you're going to be
complicated difficult what I'm saying is
trite but I brought you this long
distance because i want you to see where
I think we are and I think we can't go
back to korematsu that in my opinion
would be simply terrible but if we're
going forward we have to I tell you the
government will tell us about the
security problem will forget a brief
from the Solicitor General you think
it's going to say we were wrong will
impose this measure no it's not going to
say that it's going to say how right we
were and how are we to test that are we
to take is just his word for it or why
and how is this going to work how does
it work in Israel have systems in Israel
at our interest England Britain we're
going to do an exchange
we did an exchange of the first judges
they have a rather interesting system
there and there are other ones and
friends and how this works I'm not
saying you ought to know it out of some
intellectual curiosity I'm saying you
ought to know it because the problems
are in all likelihood going to be right
in front of the courts and whether
you're there as a judge or there is a
lawyer there is an interesting person
you have to have an idea here about how
not to go back to korematsu how to make
some progress here without blowing up
the country and without destroying civil
liberties all right so it's easy to say
to that level and then I say well it's
your problem that's because I will work
it out over time so let me so let me ask
I mean I'm trying to think about how to
take what you've said and to weave it
into your theme about this new
generation is going to face a world that
is different from the generation we have
faced and they're going to have to face
learning things knowing things about the
world that you know you we from a legal
standpoint can say that's somebody
else's problem so your thesis is that
historically back to Cicero through
Stendahl and low bear through through
the second world war first and second
world wars the attitude of law in
general was when it comes to kind of
foreign affairs whether their Wars or
national security issues or whatever we
in the legal system will defer much more
to the political judgments the branches
of government that are responsible for
conducting these we will stand back
and we will but your point is that has
led to some the great some of the
greatest injustice that the country has
committed and but secondly the world has
changed in ways that make it no longer
possible or advisable for us to step
back and just defer right let's and and
those are going to come more and more
and we what does a university do what
does a loss will do what is the School
of Public Policy do what does the
universe what do we do in law to advance
the ability to be able to address those
that changing world what the what do you
wish you know you knew now that would
help you address this rising set of
issues and problems that you don't have
can I give you one more example and
you'll see notes but yes of course you
seek is the most obvious example of this
change is in the area of cars right and
and that's easy so obvious all the
changes so obvious like what I'm going
to come for I could get four or five of
those a vitamin distributor in Ecuador
is suing a manufacturer in Holland
because he says they're part of a
price-fixing ring or that's right and
they were the the there's an American
member and he's suing for in New York
why is he suing in New York but one
possibility is you see his vitamin price
is very high you can't afford to buy
them and he's too weak to get to Holland
that's possible could have happened
another reasons treble damages all right
so he wants to sue in New York and
there's a statute and the statute which
is an American statute says whether he
can or not except it doesn't quite say
it
that clearly so we have to interpret it
now interpreting it you'd have to go
back and look at it but I would say we
could not have done it we couldn't have
done it I couldn't have done it have the
EU not filed a brief that explains very
clearly at Japan filed a brief deriving
Germany I think several different
countries and their lawyers and they
explain how the EU aunty cartel
mechanism works and you can see whether
there's interference there or not the
same things true in the securities cases
the securities cases a Australian buys a
security in the exchange in Australia
innocent an Australian company which
Australian company has bought an
American company which American company
made some money through some fraud in
Florida all right can they sue under 10
B 5 you again would not have Henry
friendly would have decided it
differently we decided no yeah and one
of the reasons know is we had briefs
from all over the world including
securities authority that's nice to stay
out of this stay out of it what you
would get into this and you will wreck
our system of dealing with the same
fraud problem and i can give you other
examples too but those will suffice
because what i want to show you is this
word comedy which used to just be some
very esoteric word in a hugely in a I
mean I took international law firm roger
fisher was viewed as a somewhat easy
course and we talked about Sabatino the
whole time they may be but that isn't
what it's like now comedy now i think
and i can give you several cases on this
is not simply you stay out of it it's
theirs it's how do you interpret an
American statute given what other people
are doing so you can harmonize and
further the similar advance of similar
areas of law in many different countries
which in the antitrust cases to stop
price-fixing which in the securities
cases to stop fraud and that requires
knowing something about it and I can
give you examples in copyright
examples all over the place you say what
the law schools do about it I said the
law schools do what they're really good
out the first thing that they're good at
is the law professors traditionally were
and I believe still are very good at
reading different cases knowing what
those cases stand for against a
background of knowledge of the area
which the judges don't have and which
not that many lawyers have then they
write about it and they say but he
didn't know over here there's this and
this is going to do that over there and
before you know it you have a treatise
or an article which rationalizes the
area which is read by the lawyers the
lawyers then when it's useful to their
case present it to the judges and the
judges see how they might improve on the
work they've done modify what they said
and backward into the circle again so
there are three parts of our profession
the judicial the lawyer part and the the
Academy I must be speaking to love but
that they work best when they work
together other thing that they taught us
in law school we hope is how to look
something up you can't teach the law of
the world nobody knows the law of the
world but you could sometimes in a
contract case bring in something by way
of comparison so that the law of the
world doesn't just end up in a course
called comparative law and international
law but bits and pieces of it even in an
antitrust course come in for a week a
week isn't that law you can teach a lot
in a week and so so there are ways of
bringing it into the curriculum because
it will be part of the lawyers life
above all to teach the lawyer how to
look things up and included in the work
of called rationalizing the law I don't
see that that's so tough cuz that's a
full professors do every day of the week
is their job but let me ask you how you
know these economic cases are I love
these economic cases and I really
enjoyed that chapter in your book very
much and I was left saying well let's
comedy you know this has been an
evolving evolving concept but for you to
even get to comedy the US has to have a
stake in reaching the conduct if it's
just a foreign against a foreign it's
not a u.s. matter so there has to be a
u.s. steak before you even get to comedy
and if we have a legitimate stake then
how do you weigh the foreign sovereign
claim or the foreign claim against the
US interest could you share your
thinking about how you think we should
be weighing these factors even in a
world where there are bilateral
agreements and foreign leniency programs
and a very complex web of relationships
but the US does have a stake and we
always will have a stay I mean if the
case is in front of us you're right
there's some US connection in the case
of the antitrust that that case there
were American consumers who did pay
higher prices because of the
international vitamin cartel ok so the
Securities matter there were people who
were affected when the Australian
company bought the company that had a
connection in Florida so there always is
some kind of an interest somewhere that
get you into the matter once you're in
it that's where the briefs come in i'll
call it was quite good as the b
statement i think of international law
or whatever it uses the word reasonable
quite a law I think that's awfully good
they might think they're not saying
anything when they say reasonable it
isn't that helpful what's helpful to me
because what it does in to the court it
allows you to work with the facts of the
case and the briefs telling you how
they're trying to run they're trying to
run their their their fraud division
over in Europe or and the other thing
now if you decide this way our whistle
blowing program is
going to go out the window see nobody
will tell us anything about what's going
on to the company because they'll be
afraid of the prosecution over there so
you've got to draw a line somewhere this
is really it seems to be very important
so let me state it and see whether this
is what you're saying so it's one thing
I always hate it when people put things
this way because it sounds like you're
drawing a distinction in fact you
haven't given a reason it's one thing to
say you know in courts it'd just be good
to find out what's happening in other
places in the world because maybe they
have some good ideas out there probably
not because we have all the good ideas
most of the time you know that kind of
thing so let's do comparative law in the
sense of look brother maybe there is
some other I that's one thing another
thing which I think I hear you saying is
a justice or a judge should have an
interest a part of his or her mind that
is trying through the decision to make a
better world a better legal world not
just the US world not just you know what
what's the US interest at stake and I my
job is to maximize that at all expensed
everything you're actually proposing
that a judge or justice try to build
through the cases a world that is better
other interests are taking into account
building internet international legal
system through this kind of ad hoc
somewhat ad hoc way but still
nevertheless the only way we have
because we don't have an international
Supreme Court that's a big step right or
wrong ninety percent right except i
think that the ten percent is that the
judge doesn't have to sit out there and
start thinking how I'd like a better
world the judge just has to do his job
yeah I mean for example you have cared
sang who is the Thai student who
at Cornell who discovers that the same
text books that he's paying for their
about half the price or something in
Bangkok in English so he says to his
parents send me a few well they sent
more than a few he began to sell them
the publisher got annoyed brought a
lawsuit and the question was does he had
the right to do that or not and the
answer lies in an American statute and
the American statute is sort of like
Wexler's footnote you can't understand
what it's saying right so I go to my
office and there is a stack of briefs
like this and from all over the world
from Asian publishers from from
governments from all over the place all
kinds of industries I couldn't figure
out why are there so many brief so
that's that's question I have you don't
necessarily have but I walk in my office
I think I'm bar all right but but in any
case there were a lot of briefs and
finally towards the bottom I get I'd
taken in the point why there are so many
because a copyright today is not simply
a question of books or books and music
and film everything it's automobiles the
software is copyrighted you go into any
store you want and look at those labels
they come from all over the world
they're all copyrighted okay and so in
one of those briefs it says your answer
to this is going to affect 2.3 trillion
dollars worth of Commerce okay that's a
lot of money even today and there we are
I didn't do that but to get the right
answer to that question which will
involve 2.3 trillion dollars it turns
out I have to know as a judge not my
free choice to make a better world I
have to know about the Berne Convention
I have to know about how other countries
publishing systems might work or might
not that's part of my job and and it
would you want to question that I think
is likely to come up which i think is
amazingly important but I think it does
it isn't there yet we've dodged it a few
times but the the look uh sabino kasai
seems a very good law professor in Italy
said his research students out answer
this question think of the United
Nations think of the World Trade
Organization what they have in common is
they are created by creed ii or some
kind of internet
agreement of some sort they have
bureaucracies those bureaucracies make
rules and those rules affect more than
citizens of more than one country
citizens or businesses is how many such
organizations are there in the world I
mean that can make rules that in
practice same whether it's law but in
practice buying people how many years
that you study how many here we think
they're more than 500 nobody thinks
they're more than 500 there are more
than 500 more than a thousand more than
1500 more than 2,000 well there are more
than 2,000 all right and we belong to
about a thousand eight hundred nine
hundred I'm you've heard of some of them
you heard of the UN here to the WTO I
might have heard of the blue fin whale
Commission what about the International
olive oil Council yeah it's a good
organization and and they're all over
the place and one of them you did
surprising this doesn't pop right into
your head because it affects your life
every single day and it isn't even a
treaty created organization I don't
think it's a corporation what affects
you most it's affected you seven times
in the last hour probably or last day
your clothes Apple it's not apple
happens a company but Apple is regulated
by who you know not everybody knows the
answer icon have you heard of icon icon
is in Los Angeles it's a company it
controls domain names who regulates icon
hmm it does affect you and by the way
when they Melbourne what about bird in
Bern they meet who the banks and the
bank regulators so the SEC send some
staff over to burn to figure out what to
do about banking and then you a lot and
then they decide and then they come back
in the SEC has notice and comment
rulemaking I see you mean it's being
decided now in the note hahaha it was
decided then in burn and Hipple in the
room
nobody except for the regulators in the
banks all right now is that going to
last I'd suspect maybe not but the
question the big question there is and
these are just small examples with that
many organizations why is there a blue
fin whale Commission because as obvious
they're in danger right there are
problems there are problems of
environment their problems of security
there are problems of health there are
problems of Commerce there are problems
and problems and problems and those
problems in a world where you will see
vast movements of people from the
countryside into cities where you will
see energy needed all over the world
where it now isn't and coming from
across borders in a world in other words
which is our world you will see the need
for rules and the question is how do you
make them and I say why is it such a big
question for us well quite simply
Congress will delegate to all those
people the power to make rules to affect
us ah if we don't how do we work with
the other countries how do we solve the
problems if they don't delegate the
power but wait if they do delegate the
power I mean when and under what
circumstances do we run into this
question article 1 of the Constitution
says that the legislative power of the
United States is in a Congress not in
the blue fin whale Commission does this
begin to sound familiar this question
it's the same question in kind that the
supreme court faced in the 30s and in
the 40s when they decided krabi medicine
what is an administrative agency what is
it how could it exists it's not in the
Constitution but they figured out a way
but they haven't yet figured out a way
for the blue fin whale Commission nor in
fact have we yet had the question
clearly pose though we have had slices
of it posed and a bond for example and
as I said we dodged it we dodged
questions like this we're just getting
into them and what will the answer be
and if you think I'm making this up go
read the German Constitutional Court or
the Italian or the Austrian having had
to decide to what extent does the
constitution of Germany give the German
government the power to sign the EU
treaties and thereby delegate
legislative power to the EU power which
the Constitution says at least to some
degree rests in the hands of the land or
the states and each one of those courts
has said it does not give them total
authority each one is said there has to
be reservations and each one has never
found an actual reservation that had
bike but nonetheless nonetheless you see
the kinds of problems well there they
are are they because of some radical
international justices no and in your
I'm sort of carried away here but to
your question with the person who
doesn't want us to refer to foreign
cases congressman good loud I used a
debate with him I like it he's a nice
guy very bright and he says I said but
he launches into a thing we shouldn't
refer to foreign cases I said well I
guess that's referring to me he says yes
that's it okay so let me tell you why
they they have I use a your they have
problems like ours their courts like us
they have documents like us why don't I
read it I might learn something he says
read it just don't refer to it so I said
well it's more than that I said there
are a lot of new courts in new countries
and they're giving power to these courts
to try to have a some kind of stopgap to
protect human liberty and they refer to
our cases if we refer to their as they
might be able to use it I'm going to
give them press TV or something go to
the legislature to say don't cut our pay
he says fine write them a letter don't
refer to it so I work out what's
bothering him what's bothering in fact
is not these sort of arguments everybody
has loads of arguments what's bothering
him is it our basic American values and
that has significant he's afraid we're
going to lose them he's afraid that in
all the judges copying is a sort of
professional
guild and they're all sort of slightly
left wing and they're all sort of data
Don you're going to end our unique and
special need to protect democracy and
human rights and divide power and not
have too much power and sensible
whatever you say that's the American
value so i write this book in large part
ain't right at him because i want to say
i agree with you i agree with you so i
want you to see that the best way in my
opinion given the list the best way to
protect our American values is to know
what's going on beyond our shores not to
short circuit that process now you have
the whole book so I very very powerful
and of course good knowing your
administrative law background and the I
mean that's a kind of insight into
globalization the evolution of global
rulemaking and global kinds of
regulations that I think is really quite
quite fascinating and of course you know
what we're talking about today and the
tension you just raised I would say is
at the base of a lot of the political
craziness we are facing right now in
this country and other countries are
facing you can't nod or agree with that
or anything but I will say it I'm free
to do that and but the you know the
sense of dislocation that many people
feel or have affected or believed might
happen is is kind of at the root of
national debate so legal systems are
this year we open it up and Jillian
pastor is going to start ok see you at
the law school
this is a audience of students and
faculty from the school of international
public affairs as well as from the
school of law and so that's the law teen
I want to thank you on all of us but
also in particular on behalf of those of
us from the law school in the legal
community here at Columbia we're so
pleased too proud to have you well thank
you very much so I got a question that
looks if it's got a vet illogical
element and a conceptual or
philosophical element of the
methodological isn't is that you know
there's a there are different ways to
incorporate ideas from foreign laws or
international laws one is just to simply
say it's okay to cycle that doesn't
become up you know you know a site that
has to be sittin cell later that can't
be taken seriously an alternative ways
to say you must consider them so my life
my first first constitution I study was
in Canada before I United States 30
years ago and Canadian Constitution has
a section called section one that
explicitly requires when considering the
scope of a writer freedom a step in
which you have to ask is this is that
this interpretation justified in a free
and democratic society it's an explicit
step i'm sure you're familiar with
comedian Constitution just from your
owning your own path and um you know
that's how much more affirmative
requirement on the on the judiciary when
interpreting the Constitution that they
have to consider that that plus has been
interpreted as requiring consideration
of other other practices and other free
and democratic societies so that's the
methodological question would you go so
far as to do that or or you just really
trying to say let's just get to the
place where it's okay sign of court in
case of a but be that the conceptual
question is this well especially if you
can see the approach that requires that
you consider it you know this is this is
the death of originalism I mean arguably
the path of saying you must certainly
they possibly even the path of saying in
may consider and weigh practices from
from foreign of the come on foreign
constitutions or practices outside the
United States
really pushes the decision-maker into a
realm of saying you know my sole source
isn't the original interpret in the
original framers intention I mean it
really is an acute arguably of original
isn't that so i i'm interested in your
comments on yeah it's very interesting
what you say and i lighted to be here
for both groups in law school reactions
just the set of reactions no problem
with may I can refer to what I want you
know what are we going to do I don't
think they'll impeach me if I site Henry
friendly and I can't I prefer to Law
Review articles you know I've heard
that's not not been heard of and and so
I can refer to what I want that's not a
problem and we're relevant fine use it
it doesn't hurt it doesn't prove it not
binding so what must must were you most
I mean you're not going to get a
sensible decision I don't think in the
am / Grand case nor where you got a
sensible decision with our friend the
copyright Kirtsaeng without it and of
course you're going to need a girl agree
with these two agree why are there three
trade cases in two years involving the
interpretation of the anti abduction of
children statute out of the hague why
when after all you know who knows
nothing about a family law I mean the
family a judge does know something about
it and they judge Getty Ginsburg up in
Cambridge used to tell people in his
court you decide yourselves make an
agreement because if I have to do it
I'll do it badly that's and hit that's
his profession that's a really tough job
and state judges know something about it
you know who knows nothing about it
federal judges and even less the Supreme
Court of the United States so why are we
doing this because it's in a treaty and
all we have to do is referee between
those groups who are strongly anti
abduction and those groups women's
groups typically who are anti spousal
abuse and feel that this is connected
okay well we're wonderful at that I put
in sarcastic quotes
I mean we don't know so why are we doing
it as I say because today marriage is
more and more a matter for people who
live in different countries that's been
heard of and it's getting more not less
I didn't do that so of course we have to
refer to what other countries do when we
interpret a treaty and that means the
people who follow these things in that
area have to be alert to the need
possibly to change the treaty is that
and in the Commerce cases I talked about
it something else and in the case like
mrs. Phil Ortega and the human rights
law it's something yet again how you
take get to get a system that will work
in the absence of a Supreme Court in
harmony and not be at each other's
throats everybody in Deitz Henry
Kissinger which I don't know what but
it's been in any case did you see the
problem different problems in different
areas and above all if you want me to
choose one that I think is absolute
importance the figure I heard the other
day not far from here but an architect
who is speaking at the UN I don't know
if he's right imagine he is he knows his
facts usually he said today there are
three billion people living in cities
three billion of those three billion 1
billion do not have enough money to buy
living space under ten thousand dollars
of the family they can't do it in 2050
no matter what we do in 2050 there are
going to be five billion people living
in cities and of those two billion will
not have the money to buy living space
no all you have to do is think I won't
do that for you you're better at me
think of the implications of that and
think that you can't stop it and think
of what the implications are going to be
Bob prefer poverty for security for wars
for movement for climate for all kinds
of things and then you will see a world
that is developing and where I jump to
with that is there has to be there has
to be if this is going to be livable and
under control systems of law that are
united in such ways that they facilitate
rather than stand as individual
obstacles to countries and people
working together through rules
regulations all kinds of different
systems to help deal with the problems
that is going to create why of course we
believe that as lawyers we all believe
that but it's more than that because
there if you do not have a system called
the rule of law there is only one other
way to deal with problems of the human
race and all you have to do is turn on
the television set and look at a few of
the things that are going on and you
will see what that means so there isn't
much choice and so that's where I see
this as being a must could I fight
Bentley MacLeod is that work okay well
thanks very much for coming to columbia
route we really appreciate that in
particular got me out of the class
because I brought my law and economics
class here to listen to this oh and
you're doing much better job than I've
ever done in class one thing I want to
do is get back to your source say but
not about American values and since I'm
an economist not a lawyer I don't have
the subtlety or the depths of knowledge
of the law but try to view things is
kind of simplistic kind of way and I was
my first book I read by you in fact was
your book on regulations reform one of
those very nice it's actually it's a
great 14 cents on Amazon yeah it's the
best dealing in amazon today I actually
use this book when I was in Canada
teaching graduate graduate
industrialization I must say it was
extremely clear and I thought my gosh
these lawyers in the US are smart but
what what I want to ask you about is is
sort of in sometimes one things you talk
about your book right now so about the
Alien Tort Statute and in particular as
an economist we try to sort of thing
well whether so we have specific goals
like we make the world a better place
then we try to think what is her best
ways of doing social control and in a
sense it's simplistic ways we have two
forms of social control I would call her
the regulatory approach and I think
Glaser and Schleifer you document the
rice rectory state in the US which is
basically sort of an ex ante type of
control system we can contrast that with
tort law which is an ex post kind of
control where you basically which I
would say services from the UK but i
would say sort of a part of American
values let me one way to think about
that it's sort of a simple point but
once easy to see is in the case of gun
control so for example in Canada we tend
to say that people shouldn't have guns
in the US as an American value we feel
people should have dogs but then they'll
face the consequence of using the gun so
in one case you have an ex ante control
over behavior the other one is expose
and sort of occurred to me i was just
reading through through your book is in
a sense when you come to alien tort law
it serves all these recurring the birds
so the first part you talk about how
Ford laws which are regulatory to
control sanity are being brought in and
I can sort of see that for some
Americans they would view this as sort
of the rise electorate have some
resistance that but then the reverse
side the tour of the Alien Tort Statute
is an example of foreigners bringing
cases in the US as a tour and tort law
azdak onimous has a lot of desirable
features that allows very rapid response
to particular wrongs and in particular
and in particular you have a venue in
the US which is a financial center
allows those wrongs to be dealt with
quickly on the reverse side the rectory
stayed one of the reasons we find
problems with it's very slow getting
climate trees for it is extremely hard
so in some sense I would like you to
comment a little bit on these these two
types of controls and to what to what
extent we can see the court in some
sense pushing American values out via
tort law which is it totally you know
when I teach law and economics to
especially by your piece of there's a
legion find sort of amazing that the
u.s. system is sort of this this
incredible view of the law which is a
rational and tries to make a world
better place a just never feed it that
way I have had that Swiss lawyers say
this to be in my class and so I I'm sort
of warning to what extent I could view
you as pushing American values out via
via tort law this is the regulatory
approach I'm hesitant to say that either
tort law regulation is a basic American
value I mean when I think a basic
American
i use i tend to think it's corny but I
tend to think of Abraham Lincoln James
Madison and and what's written into the
first ten amendments I tend to think of
the tort law regulatory system is
different objectives as you say and you
sort these things out and try to
convince people which is the better
system in this particular method I just
I just read a critique of it is true I I
mean I was quite surprised another
interest well 31 I discovered in my job
that the fact of whether I advocated
deregulation or less regulation or this
doesn't have much impact I mean I I can
as a move in case I brought up in one of
my books which was I thought was just an
example of awful ways where they tried
to clear some plot of land to the point
where if you had dirt eating children
eating dirt for you know ten years and
they shoveled in all this dirt they
still wouldn't get sick and they had to
spend 90 million dollars clearing it up
so that and there weren't any dirt
eating children and I had the case it
actually came out about to decide for
the government because the government
was right on the law they did have the
power to do that is that and that's how
it appears more often legally and i have
found in some cases we have surprisingly
given where we started 40 years ago the
EPA is using much more than I ever would
have thought they did devices to give
people incentives to move them in the
right direction and because they had
Cass Sunstein running a water but but
the fun and I just read a book about the
European efforts to control energy and
and it looks as if according to the
author of this book that the effort to
stop nuclear power which has been
successful in Germany has meant greater
reliance on coal because you have to
have cold stations in at the time you
the wind dies down and the windmills
don't turn and those cold stations are
going to actually produce more pollution
every year and the
Lucien thing the co2 things going to go
like that which it wouldn't do if they
used a fossil fuel which would be a gas
so all you've done in that question
which is very interesting for me is
you've got me back to that world which
is an absolutely fascinating world and I
am hesitant to say that one or the other
system whether its regulatory toward or
whatever it is I think those are means
and my hope is that whether it's Europe
or the United States the most efficient
means of achieving an objective ie the
least cost way of say dealing with
pollution will affect will eventually
went out and it might be you know the
wonder of this or the other thing and we
don't have too much to do with it the
basic values were dealing with I said my
little personal my wife is paying each
of our children grandchildren Grinch
twenty dollars if they can learn the
gettysburg address so they go around
saying four score their six through or
six and one is nine this is one of the
six year olds doing pretty well she's
not sing four score and seven years ago
our fathers brought forth upon this
continent a new nation conceived in
Liberty and dedicated to the proposition
that all men are created equal now we
are engaged in a great war to see if any
this nation or any nation so conceived
and so dedicated can long endure those
are the words I wanted to say to see
whether any nation so conceived and so
dedicated can long endure is that was
the question the founders put who else
was a democracy who else believed in
human rights and they didn't completely
by any means I'm anybody understand that
but they were in the right direction
that's where you should see Hamilton
baby yeah yeah fabulous fabulous they're
in the right direction and there they
are alone alone can that experiment long
endure that's what Lincoln said that's
why he says I would have bought the
Civil War regardless regardless of
slavery I wanted to prove to the world a
nation so conceived not perfect that's
true but the but but moving there maybe
and that it's at that level
that I think that well our experiment
has not been perfect it sure hasn't but
nonetheless nonetheless and that I think
is the challenge in the biggest possible
terms that is being posed when you look
at this world which has nothing to do
with ideology or the need to get
together to help make it a little bit
better here there in the other places
which has nothing to do with ideology
but that's where we as lawyers have a
role to play and it's at that level that
I think yes you see congressman good
laugh we do have something to offer we
do have something to offer it's called
some experience with the rule of law
some good some bad and we can offer it
and we can learn from others who are
trying to do somewhat similar things so
at least we don't go down the totally
wrong drain you say you got the idea yes
a couple are a couple more questions all
right I invite um at night if yes
justice thank you for your public
service here an inspiration to the
profession I have a rather relatively
fanciful question but if you'll indulge
me if you could have your way and one of
our founders could be brought back
tonight to have dinner with you which
one would you choose and what would you
discuss with Hamilton Columbia how has
it changed nothing I'm you can't see
that you can't see it without thinking
oh my gosh that's really was something
he really was and I did Reacher knows
but and I'd stick to my answer even if I
hadn't seen musical but but my gosh I
mean he was certainly a brilliant
brilliant man and his heart was in the
right place I most of the nominee
divided practical developed these
institutions how did you do it and the
rear their work yeah why did he went
over to I gather he went over to England
and stole all the business plans from
the spot cotton mills and brought them
back over here that was a useful
exchange of information
but isn't that relative relevant to your
thesis the only impression as a
layperson in this area that I've gotten
from I do read some of the history books
i read Gordon would I read Alice I've
rattled quite a few of the biographies I
read this recent one the quartet who
knows have you seen that Lizzie and the
one impression I think maybe it's unfair
but I think I come away with it is the
one thing you said could see about the
founders what they thought in terms of
any of these really details of how
things would evolve is they didn't know
and they all caught different things and
many of them thought very different
things and so they wrote this document
and the one thing they wanted that
document to do was to endure and they
wanted those certain basic values to
endure but as soon as you get more
specific than that Bob more directions
that's my impression onions good evening
Justice Breyer it's a great pleasure to
listen to you I have to tell you when I
found your book and read your book last
year you really made my year as somebody
who had been working and consider myself
as a global person you provided a lot of
arguments and reasoning that I could use
and I've been advocating for people to
read your book I'm running a new
initiative we're not so new now that
president Bollinger established which is
looking at the establishment of global
norms how do they come about and we're
particularly interested with the role of
the judicial sector judges like you
that's why that book was so so important
because I don't want you to think that
the United States is so behind in terms
of looking at the international
perspective we did a little survey of
the world and there are only two
continents at the moment that our whose
judicial sector is slightly interested
in the way other judicial
actors are looking at issues related to
information technology and expression
it's Latin America and it's Africa and a
little bit in Europe but if you look at
the world there is a vast majority of of
the world that is whose judicial sector
is very inward looking there is
absolutely no international perspective
even in considering issues such as
information information technology and
expression that are by their very nature
global so my question to you is maybe to
follow up a bit on on what Lee was
saying is really more practical one is
how how do we instill in the the new
generations of judges in the judicial
sectors in the courts the tools the
desire and the skills to become a global
legal thinker and a global legal actor
you'll have the students there is no
more powerful weapon you you will train
the students there'll be the ones
they're going to go to work for law
firms a lot of them and a lot of those
law firms will indeed have to know
exactly given who they're advising how
things work in different countries and
you will have taught them how to find
out and you will have taught them for
example of that there are cases a grant
case in the DC Circuit so what is is is
a case involving whether i think it was
whether an environment environmental
impact statement is required by law and
the law that was at issue was a law
consisting of an agreement of a
committee of one of these international
organizations about co2 did that count
as the Lord didn't it it wasn't a law
passed by Congress that's the kind of
case that is right here and you can find
quite a few of those cases so you savior
yeah you say to the class well well how
are you gonna answer this you know hey
somebody else evidence to the two sides
all right what's the answer I'm not sure
the academic sector particularly the law
school have actually gotten to that
stage where they create the new legal
thinker that are internationally minded
oh yeah they will I mean I believe they
will because the teachers will have to a
stay one step ahead of the students and
so if they have to stay a step ahead of
the students they have to find out the
answers to these things now find it so
interesting you'll begin to write books
about them and indeed because they begin
to write books that include American law
it won't be on the shelf that says just
Oh international law and other esoterica
it will be it will be with everybody
else see because there's so many
problems well it seems to me that law
professors love problems that's what
they're in this area and they'll find
these problems and they will have
international impasse and so they think
think of the uniform law commission
before the uniform law commission's
print people tended to think there was a
commercial law of Delaware and there's a
commercial law of Iowa and the lawyers
from Idaho began to think of the
commercial law of Idaho and then
gradually the commissioners who were
from many different states went around
and began to think of what would be the
better law in different places think of
Lanza's they the American Law Institute
the American Law Institute worked out
that there was to be and there in the
international area now too I think it is
a question of for the Economist say is
law all right all right yes and dick
stuart is doing its part so you will
teach the students how to find out what
they need to know if they're going to
practice at linklaters and you will in
fact stay three steps ahead of them and
lots not all law professors and not all
economics professors and not all
political professors will be interested
in this but you don't need all just need
a few
and then they will be I mean I'm not
pessimistic about that I do indeed when
the judges find out that you're reading
their opinions they'll be delighted
normally I opinion I say they should go
round out and never forget that that's
brighter so I optimistic so let me say
on behalf of all of us we really
appreciate and enjoy this time with you
Merritt do you want to say anything no I
think it's been a marvelous discussion I
wish we had more time but we'll find
another time I hope thanks so much
thank you thank you so much